cuando dos ondas se traslapan en el
mismo medio decimos que hay una
interferencia de onda podemos imaginar
que esta caja es una bocina y esta es la
onda de audio que genera o podría
representar a un láser y está la onda de
luz que genera o incluso podría ser un
generador de ondas bolas en un tanque y
está la onda que genera en el agua si
tenemos una segunda fuente de onda y
ambas se traslapan vamos a tener
interferencia de onda que se va a ver
más o menos así imaginemos que éstas son
bocinas me gusta este ejemplo porque es
muy fácil de imaginar pongo una bocina
junto a la otra y así crearemos ondas de
audio en esta región y no necesariamente
voy a tener dos ondas de audio podemos
imaginarlo como tener una onda total de
audio como encontraremos el tamaño de
esta onda total podemos poner un eje
aquí que me ayudará a pensar sobre esto
lo pongo aquí y ahora nos preguntamos
cuál fue el valor de la primera onda
tomamos este valor
fue el valor de la segunda onda ahora
vamos a sumar ambos valores y el
resultado será el valor de la onda total
que en este caso se duplica
y ahora tomo este punto y veo cuánto
vale en la primera onda y en la segunda
onda y los 1 de nuevo se duplica y ahora
el punto en la onda total no va a ser
tan alto como el anterior aquí voy a
tener cero y ya nos vamos dando cuenta
de lo que sucede aquí aquí abajo vamos a
tener cantidades negativas que se
duplican y si gráfica mos y si gráfica
mos esto tendremos una gran onda total
de audio que luce así esta amplificada
aquí tenemos una posibilidad cuando se
traslapan dos ondas como es este caso en
donde los picos coinciden y los valles
también coinciden ésto es una
interferencia constructiva cuando los
picos coinciden y los valles coinciden
tendremos lo que se llama interferencia
constructiva porque estas ondas se
combinan de forma constructiva y generan
una onda más grande
qué es lo que escucharíamos y nuestro
oído se encontrará por acá esperando
escuchar el sonido pues escucharíamos
una nota con volumen alto mucho más alta
que la original el doble de alto de
hecho
lo que tiene sentido ya que tenemos dos
bocinas y por eso es el doble de alto lo
que es un poco más difícil de comprender
es que también podemos tener algo
llamado interferencia destructiva como
luce esto imaginen que tenemos dos
bocinas pero ahora las ondas lucen así
el pico de una onda coincide con el
valle de la otra y el valle de la
primera onda coincide con el pico de la
segunda estas ondas están fuera de fase
antes cuando se veían así estas ondas
decimos que están en fase porque lucen
idénticas los picos con los picos y los
valles con los reyes en cambio éstas se
encuentran fuera de fase que tan lejos
se encuentran de la fase digamos que
éstas se encuentran desfasadas 180
grados la fase se refiere a qué punto en
el ciclo de la onda se encuentra la onda
y estas dos comienzan por completo
separadas
quizás piensen que la diferencia es de
360 grados pero piensen que si dan una
vuelta de 360 grados terminarán en el
mismo lugar si debes pasamos estas ondas
360 grados terminarán luciendo igual es
por eso que estas están desfasadas 180
grados para que queden exactamente
opuestas que coincidan picos con valles
o si les gustan los radiales estarán y
fuera de fase porque pi es igual a 180
grados
ahora tomo estas dos bocinas y las vamos
a poner en el mismo lugar y nos va a
quedar algo así y ahora lo que va a
pasar es que si agregó mi eje para
ayudarme a visualizar esto
voy a calcular cómo queda mi onda total
tomo este valor en la primera onda y lo
sumo el valor de este punto en la
segunda onda sumo una cantidad positiva
con una negativa y me queda hacer por
acá tenemos 0 + 0 que nos dé a 0 y ahora
sumamos el valle de la primera onda con
el pico de la segunda onda y a sumar
ambos valores me queda de nuevo 0
seguramente ustedes ya saben lo que va a
pasar aquí vamos a tener una línea plana
y nada de ondas estas dos ondas se
cancelan mutuamente y a esto le llamamos
no interferencia constructiva sino
interferencia destructiva ya que estas
ondas se combinan de forma destructiva
para no formar onda alguna lo cual es
muy extraño cómo es posible que dos
ondas no produzcan onda alguna pues es
así como sucede si tuviéramos nuestro
oído aquí que escucharíamos si
tuviéramos solo una bocina escucharíamos
sonido
si sólo tuviéramos la segunda bocina
también escucharemos sonido pero si
tuviéramos ambas bocinas al mismo tiempo
no escucharemos nada solo silencio esto
es difícil de creer pero es cierto así
es como funcionan los audífonos que
cancelan ruido si tomamos una señal
exterior y enviamos exactamente la misma
señal pero desfasada en sus fases o
desfasada 180 grados se van a cancelar
por lo que podemos combatir el ruido con
más ruido si lo tenemos exactamente
fuera de fase tendremos silencio o algo
muy similar y ustedes pueden preguntarse
cómo hacemos para que en una bocina
tengamos la onda desfasada 180 grados no
es difícil si se fijan en la parte de
atrás de la bocina vamos a limpiar esto
dentro veremos una terminal positiva y
una terminal negativa y podemos
intercambiar la terminal positiva con la
terminal negativa y viceversa de manera
que cuando una bocina trate de empujar
el aire hacia afuera de manera que
cuando una bocina trate de empujar el
aire hacia afuera recuerden que la
bocina tiene un diafragma que se mueve
hacia adelante y hacia atrás cuando una
de las bocinas trate de empujar el aire
hacia afuera
la otra bocina tratará de jalar el aire
hacia adentro por lo que el resultado
neto es que el aire no se va a mover
pues tenemos fuerzas iguales y opuestas
en el el aire no se mueve y por lo tanto
no habrá sonido ya que el aire tiene que
oscilar para transmitir sonido por lo
que tenemos interferencia destructiva
esta es la forma en la que podemos poner
una bocina fuera de fase
aunque es posible que ustedes no quieran
meterse con el cableado de sus bocinas y
de hecho no deberían hacerlo si no
quieren recibir un choque eléctrico pero
si tengo dos bocinas en fase quizás
piensen que no hay forma de tener
interferencia destructiva pero si la hay
sin tener que meterse con los cables
cuando queríamos las bocinas en fase
solo tuvimos que alinear las para tener
interferencia constructiva pero no tengo
porqué poner las juntas puedo poner una
de las bocinas ligeramente por delante
de la otra y vean lo que sucede se van
desfasando mi pregunta es qué tan lejos
debo de poner las bocinas para tener una
interferencia destructiva
vamos moviéndola hasta que luzca así
ahora está fuera de fase y tendremos
interferencia destructiva qué tan lejos
movi la bocina hacia adelante si nos
fijamos aquí estaba el frente de la
bocina originalmente y ahora quedó el
frente de la bocina aquí que tanto de la
longitud de onda movie la bocina pues
fue la mitad de la longitud de la onda
si tomamos dos bocinas que están en fase
y movemos una hacia adelante la mitad de
la longitud de la onda tendremos
interferencia destructiva si pongo mi
oreja aquí no escucharé nada ya que
aunque estaban en fase movía una bocina
media longitud de onda hacia adelante
alineándose de manera destructiva y no
escucharé nada pero si regresamos a como
estábamos al principio si no vemos la
bocina hacia adelante toda una longitud
de onda
ahora tendremos de nuevo una
interferencia constructiva así que si
nos movemos toda una longitud de onda
como lo estoy marcando aquí en nuestra
bocina estaba aquí y ahora está acá todo
esto es una longitud de onda completa y
tengo interferencia constructiva y ahora
escucharé el doble de sonido que con una
sola bocina así que la moraleja de la
historia es que podemos tener
interferencia constructiva o destructiva
con bocinas que están en fase
dependiendo de la diferencia en la
longitud que ambas ondas viajan la onda
2 viaja esta distancia para llegar a mi
oído que le llamaré x2 y la onda 1 viaja
a esta distancia para llegar a mi oído y
les llamaré x1 ahora vemos la diferencia
entre x2 y x1 la diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta que viajan estas
ondas y que será esta cantidad a esta
diferencia la llamaremos delta x
y vimos que si esto es igual a lambda
tendremos interferencia constructiva y
si esto es igual a la mitad de lambda
tendremos interferencia destructiva pero
estos no son los únicos valores que
podemos tener y voy a escribir este
resultado importante si delta x es igual
a lambda o 2 landa o 3 lambda imaginen
que movemos esta bocina otra longitud de
onda completa tendremos las ondas en
fase nuevamente cualquier valor entero
que multiplique a lambda incluyendo 0
nos va a dar interferencia constructiva
incluimos 0 porque es el caso en el que
tendremos más bocinas en el mismo lugar
tendremos interferencia constructiva
siempre que las ondas estén en fase
también vimos que a la mitad de la
longitud de onda
encontramos interferencia destructiva
pero este no es el único caso en el que
podemos encontrarla cualquier mitad de
onda multiplicado por un impar también
nos dará interferencia destructiva no
puede obtener dos entre dos porque sería
igual a lambda pero si puedo tener a
tres lambda entre 2 o 5 holanda entre 2
o 7 de lambda entre 2 cualquiera de esto
nos dará interferencia destructiva pues
causará que coincidan los picos con los
valles de manera que se cancele el
sonido
este es un resultado importante si
tenemos dos bocinas que estén en fase es
decir que comiencen con la misma onda
la segunda bocina inicia su onda de la
misma manera que la primera bocina
inicia su onda la única diferencia será
la diferencia en la longitud de la ruta
este es un resultado importante porque
nos permite saber si tenemos una
interferencia constructiva o destructiva
pero esto es suponiendo que no tenemos
diferencia alguna en la fase desde el
inicio qué pasaría si yo manipuló y
cableado de una de las bocinas e
intercambio los cables de las terminales
positiva y negativa de manera que la
onda de la primera bocina sale hacia
arriba cuando la onda de la segunda
bocina sale hacia abajo qué pasará en
este caso pues se pueden imaginar que
estos resultados se van a intercambiar
si vemos este caso en el que comenzamos
con dos ondas fuera de fase y ahora sí
comenzamos con una diferencia de cero en
las longitudes de las rutas tendremos
una interferencia destructiva en lugar
de una interferencia constructiva y si
muevo todo esto una longitud de onda
hacia adelante de nuevo tendré
interferencia destructiva y lo mismo
tendré si la muevo 2 lambda de distancia
y así sucesivamente por lo que los
múltiplos enteros de lambda nos darán
interferencia destructiva qué pasa con
las mitades de longitud de onda aquí
podemos ver qué
da una interferencia constructiva con
las zonas en fase si la adelantó tres
medios de lambda también tendré las
zonas alineadas y una interferencia
constructiva así que si comenzamos con
dos fuentes que están desfasadas y veces
tendremos lo contrario de lo que tuvimos
en el resultado anterior si una bocina
está desfasada ibex es de la otra bocina
y recuerden que no tienen que ser
bocinas pueden ser cualquier fuente de
onda
si esto sucede entonces vamos a
intercambiar los resultados ahora éstos
nos darán las interferencias
constructivas y estos otros nos darán
las interferencias destructivas
tendremos los resultados opuestos aquí
tengo que insistir nuevamente que esto
no aplica solamente para bocinas también
aplica para la luz en experimentos de
doble rejilla y también para
experimentos de membrana delgada también
aplica para ondas en el agua y para
cualquier fuente de onda es la regla
fundamental para casi todos los aspectos
de la interferencia de ondas la
diferencia de la longitud de la ruta en
conjunto con el hecho de que haya un
desfasamiento de pi relativo entre las
dos ondas o no determinarán si tenemos
una interferencia constructiva o
destructiva